- The first thing I thought as a singer
having to do videos all the time
and having to time things with the lyrics,
when you did the entrance and the song,
I was like, how many times
did you have to do that?
- I think 27 was the
official take on the day,
because Fred--
- Was that, like,
one of the hardest ones?
- Fred had fourteen years
in order to figure this out.
It was nearly impossible.
You'd think that song
will last a long time.
- It's not.
- That song does not
last a long time when you
gotta carry a thing in,
take off a jacket, open closet door,
pull a sweater off a hanger,
put the jacket on the hanger,
- I had a mini panic attack
watching it.
- Mari, the boss, Mari
Heller, our director,
she confessed to me later
on that she blew it,
that she could've made it easier
because she found out
that Fred's blue shoes
were already halfway tied.
(Kelly gasps)
They were bigger than his feet anyway,
so they went on really easy,
then the shoes that come off
are also bigger than my feet,
so those come off easy, but
I had to do the full tie,
you know, criss-cross
applesauce, you know.
- I watched!
- Rabbit goes around the ear.
- Yes!
- I had to do that whole thing.
He only had to do the fly
around the rabbit's ear.
- Oh, my gosh!
- It was a nightmare!
(Kelly laughs)